[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and I'm coming at you
live from Europe well technically this
is not live it was definitely
pre-recorded but it is still from Europe
and I know what you must be thinking oh
look it's another youtuber comparing two
of the most popular trapped in a game a
Sakai anime and praising overlord while
bashing sword art online how original
but let me stop you right there while I
do personally prefer overlord and I will
explain why I think that Sao has gotten
way more hate than it actually deserves
and it is nowhere near the worst anime
that I have ever seen even though I like
Overlord a lot more in this video I will
also talk about one specific issue that
I see in overlord which I think Sao
actually handles better and as a fan of
overlord and as someone who wants to see
this series succeed and reach an even
wider audience I will talk about why
this issue might be hurting Overlord and
how it could be resolved in the future
but first let me talk about why I prefer
Overlord to Sao before getting into the
one problem I see with Overlord it is
important to say that Overlord has two
specific advantages over Sao and many
other yokai anime Overlord spends a lot
more time really focusing on two things
that are incredibly important to every
good story world building and strategy
and by the way if you want to see more
Overlord content on this channel you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell in Sao we are introduced to a very
interesting virtual world and personally
I thought that the first episode of Sao
was one of the best first episodes in
anime and it absolutely drew me in but
as the series progressed almost all of
the world building we see comes to us
from the perspective of Kirito the
blatantly overpowered protagonist Kirito
is an exceptional player who can solve
nearly all of his problems
with his superior swordsmanship
abilities and while this is explained by
the fact that he was one of the 1,000
beta testers so he had more experience
with the game when it launched and the
average player it is hard to have good
world building in a story where we are
almost always following a protagonist
who can overcome all challenges by the
virtue of his own pure awesomeness on
top of that because so much attention is
given to Kirito and his awesomeness the
initial virtual world of aincrad cannot
sustain the story for long so the series
follows Kirito into different game
worlds including Alfheim and gun Gale
online so instead of fully developing
the initial virtual world we just move
on to the next one and we have to
pretend that after the disastrous
failure that was the initial sao game
which resulted in literally thousands of
people dying it still makes perfect
sense to keep introducing and playing
more games that work in an extremely
similar way as the deadly original and
because of the fact that we have to keep
moving into different worlds just to
find new challenges for the incredible
king among men that is Kirito the vast
majority of the side characters are only
relevant for a few episodes before being
absorbed into key little shadow harem of
irrelevancy once a new arc comes along
and their presence is no longer needed
Lizbeth the blacksmith is important for
a few episodes of the AI Incred arc
before being swept aside for Asuna leave
the kinky cousin is the main female
protagonist in the Alfheim arc before
fading into obscurity once that arc ants
and sin known as the main female
character in gun Gale online but she
predictably becomes just a background
extra once Katy told lightsabers the
crap out of all the bad guys in that
world and I guess silica was a thing at
some point maybe anyway you catch my
drift and while I realized that some of
these characters will play significant
roles in the upcoming Alice's Asian arc
that doesn't change the fact that they
were swept aside for large periods of
the story after initially be
extremely important and in stark
contrast to Sao Overlord spends a lot of
time on building the one fantasy world
that is introduced to us in the
beginning and overlord goes to great
lengths to introduce a large number of
secondary characters who have their own
unique personalities backstories and
motivations the main protagonist in Zul
gone is definitely overpowered and in
that way we can say that he is pretty
similar to Kirito
but unlike Kirito who seems to be able
to solve all of his problems with a good
sword fight inés finds himself in a much
more complex situation even though in
reality he is just an ordinary Japanese
salaryman with no experience ruling or
being a leader from the very beginning
inés finds himself in a situation where
he has to pretend to be an all-powerful
and tactically brilliant ruler and
Conqueror as soon as he becomes trapped
inside the game he loved to play inés
finds himself being worshipped by the
floor Guardians and other inhabitants of
the great tomb of Nazareth as the only
Supreme Being who hasn't abandoned them
the residents of Nazareth see Ines as a
godly presence someone who is
all-powerful and also a tactical genius
someone who never makes mistakes and
always knows what's best for everyone
they all have such massive expectations
of pines and he has to do his best to
live up to all of them despite the fact
that he is not really some sort of
Supreme Being instead he is just an
ordinary Japanese man who happens to
love fantasy based games on top of
needing to appear to be all-powerful and
all-knowing despite being anything but
minds has to deal with the fact that
although the world he is trapped in is
similar to the world of the game that he
loved to play it is not the same world
there are many unknowns here things that
eyes has no way of knowing or
understanding so he is forced to slowly
explore this new world and learn more
about it while at the same time
pretending to have some master plan for
world domination up his sleeve
Ines knows that if he was somehow
transported into this game world then it
is possible that another player from the
game
might have been transported there as
well maybe even multiple other players
this means that there could be other
incredibly powerful creatures like
himself hiding away somewhere in this
new world and although the vast majority
of the creatures that live in this world
are no match for inés its power there is
always a possibility that someone out
there is as powerful or even more
powerful than eyes this means that is
has to be careful he cannot simply go
out and announce his intentions to the
world and he cannot simply try to subdue
everyone by force because he still
doesn't know what type of enemy he will
ultimately be up against in the climax
of season Juana inés is forced to fight
shall tear whose mind is being
controlled by a mysterious enemy an
enemy who has the ability to use world
items this important part of the story
emphasizes that there are still unknown
threats out there that perhaps even Ines
as overpowered as he is may not be able
to overcome so he has to be careful and
cautious related to that politics and
strategy are a crucial aspect of
overlord whereas they are clearly not
the central theme in Sao by any stretch
of the imagination as someone who has
studied politics and international
relations for many years I actually love
this aspect of overlord and it is one of
the reasons why I truly appreciate this
show being an overlord and ruling over
people and lands is not an easy task
especially if you're just a normal
salary man who has been thrust into such
an unfamiliar situation even if you have
a lot of power as Ines and the other
residents of Nazareth certainly do pure
power alone is not enough to rule the
world in episode 9 of season 3 Ines
explains to the Guardians that ruling
through absolute power would be easy but
that method creates too many enemies it
helps to think of this in terms of
international relations even if one
country had by far the strongest army in
the world it would still be foolish for
this powerful country to wage war
against every other country in the world
at the same time no matter how strong
you are on
your own if you make too many enemies
and if you attack without knowing your
enemy well and without knowing all the
tricks they may be hiding up their
sleeves you are heading for disaster
Ines is fully aware of this and he has
to walk an incredibly fine line between
keeping up appearances as this brilliant
and unstoppable conqueror while
attempting to learn more about this
mysterious world that he finds himself
in sometimes he has to be cruel and
ruthless to keep his enemies on the run
and to keep up his reputation with the
Guardians
and other times he has to show mercy so
as not to make too many enemies
so unlike Kirito Ines cannot solve all
of his problems with a sword fight he
has to grapple with politics strategy
and international relations and all of
this makes the world of overlord much
more complex than the world of Sao and
much more similar to the real world in
addition the fact that Ines character in
the game is supposed to be evil a member
of the undead adds further nuance to his
character on the inside he is just an
ordinary human but on the outside he is
a powerful undead sorcerer who is
expected to see humans as inferior
beings as mere pray for him and his kind
because of this Ines finds himself
forced to sometimes do things that we
would consider evil under normal
circumstances and it is fascinating to
see Ines navigating through these
difficult situations but he dicho
doesn't have such dilemmas he is
generally a calm and cool badass who
always does the right thing and saves
the day Kirito also faces emotional
dilemmas to be sure but these are
definitely not on the same level or
scale as the dilemmas that Ines has to
deal with it is this attention to detail
in terms of world building and strategy
as well as the complexities of Lines's
character then make overlord a far
superior series to Sao in my opinion but
I have to be honest here and say that
overlord does have one important issue
and it is an issue that Sao actually
tackles more successfully than Overlord
and the reason why I bring up this
problem is not because I
to bash overlord as a fan of the series
I most certainly don't want to do that
but I bring this up because I feel that
this problem may prevent more people
from getting into this series in the
future the problem that I am talking
about is the fact that overlords
detailed world building sometimes goes
too far too many side characters are
constantly being introduced to the point
that it is impossible to keep up with
all of them and to the point that we
don't get to see eyes and the main cast
from Nazareth often enough to be clear
the side characters in overlord are not
like the side characters in Sao by and
large they are not one dimensional and
time is spent actually developing these
characters and their personalities
what's more all of these characters
serve some purpose in the greater
stories so they are not throwaway
characters and while this is usually a
good thing in overlord there are just
too many side characters the swords of
Darkness The Lizard Men the blue roses
the people in carne village all the
nobles Andrea steez Forsyte the Emperor
of the baka Ruth Empire and all the
people around him and so on and so on I
mean can anyone even keep track of all
of these people's names I certainly
can't and I doubt any casual fan can
either unless they keep looking up all
the characters online I mean just look
at the Gilgamesh wannabe emperor dude
his name is jerk nib rune far Lord el
Nix yeah do you think I remembered any
part of that when I was watching him on
screen definitely not I only learned his
name when I had to look it up for this
video on top of that I couldn't care
less about him as a character this is
literally my face when I see him appear
on screen this is a problem because the
strength of overlord is how great eyes
is as a lead character and yet so much
time is spent focusing on side
characters many of whom just end up
dying a few episodes later instead of
focusing on the characters of Ines and
his relationship with the Guardians
Nazareth which is what I want to see a
lot more of I mean even if you're a
die-hard fan of all things overlord you
love everything about it I think we can
all agree that we need to see more vines
and less of emperor discount Gilgamesh I
know that all of these side characters
do play a role in the story they are not
just throw aways but spending so much
time on side characters inside stories
hurts the pacing of the show and casual
fans looking to get into overlord will
find it extremely difficult to keep up
with all of these dozens and dozens of
side characters from various villages
and kingdoms and empires and this might
eventually turn them off from the series
I myself am a published writer of
fiction and one of the most common
criticisms that a writer can receive is
that his or her story has too many
characters and because of this it is
hard to keep track of all of them your
editors will often suggest focusing the
story on a smaller group of characters
or blending multiple similar characters
into a single character I think that
Overlord definitely suffers from this
problem too many side characters taking
up too much time in the story and
ultimately this hurts the pacing and
takes the focus away from the characters
that we are really interested in like
ions Sao does a terrible job of making
its side characters important to the
story and most of them end up being
throwaway characters that don't serve a
significant purpose but the people who
do love sao love it for Kirito the
protagonist and they watch it because
they want to see Kirito being awesome
the creators of sao are fully aware of
this and in this regard they deliver
they give us all the kitty to badassery
that we can handle and the fans who are
into that really love it the one story
arc which shifts away from that is
mother's Rosario although this is
technically not even an actual arc but
just a side story this story shifts the
focus to Asuna and some of the new
friends she meets in new minecraft a lot
of people have praised this Side Story
for changing things up and finally
giving some of the other characters time
to shine but to me personally this side
story felt incredibly contrived we are
suddenly introduced to a bunch of new
characters who are part of a guild known
as the sleeping 9
and we are expected to instantly care
about them but it was all way too fast
the characters received almost no
development apart from Yuki and I just
did not feel any sort of attachment to
these random people who suddenly become
asanas BFFs overnight and this is what
I'm afraid will happen to overlord if we
keep going down the road of dozens of
dozens of new characters constantly
being introduced and the story
gravitating towards them for episodes on
end instead of focusing on the main
characters we love and want to learn
more about like Ines and the Guardians
Overlord is without a doubt the far
superior series to Sao in my opinion but
it is not perfect and I am NOT one of
those people who will pretend that it is
if there is one thing that overlord can
learn from Sao it is that more attention
must be given to the main characters
especially when they are as interesting
as the main cast of overlord I want more
inés more albedo more shouts here more
aura and mata and more Pandora's actor
for the love of but anyway let me know
what you guys do do you agree with me
about Overlord and the need to put a
stronger focus on the main cast even
though the world-building a strategy of
the series still place it leaps ahead of
Sao in my opinion or are you fine with
the way things are
or maybe you actually like Sao more than
Overlord let me know down below if you
enjoy this type of content and you want
to see more Overlord videos here on the
channel you can leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell you can also hit us up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
if you want to give us suggestions for
future videos as always thank you all so
much for watching and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]
you